حرب تانيه دفعت النظام الصحيه في السودان
الى حافه الانهيار لتصبح الازمه ازمتين
تزيد من ماساه الشعب السوداني الذي اتخن
بالجراح في بلد لم يعرف الاستقرار التام
منذ عقود وهو الان ضحيه السيناريو الاسوا
ارقام صادمه لعدد المستشفيات التي اصبحت
خارج الخدمه في ذروه احتياج المواطنين لها
سبعون في المئه من المرافق الصحيه اوقفت
عن العمل او اجبرت على الاغلاق بحسب نقابه
اطباء السودان فمن اصل 74 مستشفى في
العاصمه والولايات التي تقع بالقرب من
مناطق الاشتباك يوجد 52 مستشفى منها اصبحت
خارج الخدمه تماما بعد الاشتباكات الاخيره
تسعه مستشفيات منها تعرضت القصف الشديد
وتسعه عشر مستشفى اخر تعرضت للاخلاء
القصري ما يعني وجود
مستشفى فقط في المنطقه تعمل بشكل كامل او
جزئي وهي الاخرى مهدده بالاغلاق في اي
لحظه بسبب انقطاع التيار الكهربائي
وانعدام الادويه وغياب الكوادر الصحيه
فهذه المرافق الطبيه تعمل بالحد الادنى من
الامكانيات والحد الاقصى من انعدام الامن
حولها
نظام الرعايه الصحيه في السودان يمكن ان
ينهر تماما تحتاج المستشفيات الى موظفين
اضافي وتحتاج الى امدادات اضافيه وتحتاج
الى امدادات دم اضافي هناك تقريبا هجوم
عسكري على عدد من المؤسسات الصحيه هناك
يعني هجوم على سيارات اسعاف وبها مرضى
وبها عاملين صحيين وعلى الرغم من تصاعد
التحذيرات الدوليه من كارثه انسانيه
وانهيار القطاع الصحي في البلاد الا ان
القتال لازال يتواصل في عاصمه السودانيه
ومدن اخرى لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات